Корнеліус Голембєвскі агітує
за Християнсько-демократичний союз
у східнонімецькому місті Йена.
“Доброго дня, я від ХДС."
Напередодні парламентських виборів
партія Анґели Меркель - ХДС - вдалася до
старого перевіреного методу агітації -
візити додому і особисте спілкування
з виборцями. Цим займаються
такі волонтери як Голембєвскі.
А допомагають їм у цьому нові технології.
"Після того, як ми поспілкувалися
з мешканцем, дістаємо смартфон
і позначаємо, в якому районі
ми перебуваємо та оцінюємо
реакцію нашого співрозмовника -
була вона позитивною чи негативною.
Тут, як на мене,
розмова пройшла в позитивному руслі.
Тож, зберігаємо дані, отримуємо сто пунктів
і рушаємо далі".
Програма опрацьовує
також статистичні дані про вік,
стать потенційних виборців і які теми
їх найбільше цікавлять. Отримана інформація
передається до бази даних. За допомогою
додатку волонтери бачать ті райони міста,
де ймовірно проживає особливо багато
прихильників Християнсько-демократичного союзу.
"Додаток допомагає отримати загальне уявлення, в яких
районах міста наша адресна агітація
має шанс бути найбільш успішною
і продуктивною".
Новомодне програмне забезпечення
створив стартап з міста Єни.
Всі провідні партії Німеччини
взяли на озброєння великі бази даних.
Основна перевага -
агітація стає адресною.
"Партіям важливо оцінити,
чого вже досягнуто,
яка у них цільова аудиторія,
Питання анонімні,
але допомагають зрозуміти,
які бесіди велися,
які теми найбільш актуальні для виборців,
де люди, можливо, незадоволені роботою політиків,
які райони варто відвідати ще раз
Уперше бази даних потенційних виборців
під час передвиборчої компанії почали використовувати в США.
Американські партії витрачають мільйони, щоб отримати персональні дані зареєстрованих виборців.
У Німеччині заборонено збирати персональні дані
виборців, тож інформація про них є
анонімною, без імен та адрес.
Однак навіть анонімні дані на вагу золота в розробці
стратегії передвиборчої кампанії,
і мобільний додаток пропонує партіям
саме це.
Але головні успіхи розробники програми
бачать в тому, що тепер налагодиться
більш конкретний діалог з виборцями
і політики дізнаються про конкретні
побажання
і проблеми громадян.